Henrik im Bruder Nurpur hat heute glaube
ich geschrieben wenn man schon dabei war
kann man auch nebenbei noch mal kurz ein
Kalifat fordern was geht ihn durch den
Kopf wenn sie diese Bilder sehen allahu
akbar rufe 3000 Leute in der Essener
Innenstadt offiziell pro
palästinensische Demonstration wenn man
da mal genauer hinschaut merkt man
Palästina spielt in Wahrheit gar keine
Rolle das ist die eine Demo gewesen die
am härtesten war bisher das ist sehr
offensichtlich eine islamistendemo äh
wir haben auch bei den äh bei den dem
tion die für Palästina aufgerufen haben
viele fehlerentwicklung gehabt viele
Dinge die nicht n am Rande passiert sind
die nicht gehen die eindeutig
antisemitisch sind aber diese
Demonstration war was komplett anderes
diese Demonstration war tatsächlich die
Essen jetzten war tatsächlich eine wo es
wo es nichts mehr mit zu tun hat mit der
Situation im Nahen Osten nichts mit dem
Krieg gegen is auch noch Männer und
Frauen getrennt vielleicht Ken Sequenz
noch mal kurz zuspielen ist auch
interessant diese Bilder hier zu sehen
noch mal ist das erlaubt warum warum
lassen wir sowas durchgehen
ich habe jetzt diese Sprüche gehört
diese diese Slogans gehört da sehen wir
das ne die Trennung zwischen zwischen
Geschlecht ja es gibt
es gibt in diesem Land ein ein
Grundrecht auf Versammlungsfreiheit und
es gibt das Strafgesetzbuch
Strafgesetzbuch verbietet Aufrufe zu
Gewalt
Volksverhetzung wer wer sagt dass dass
er sich freut dass Menschen jetzt in in
Israel auf dem Festival umgebracht
worden sind macht die strafbar wir haben
ein umsetzungsthema wir müssen uns darum
kümmern dass diese Leute auch sehr klar
und deutlich zur Rechenschaft gezogen
werden aber diese Demonstration ist ein
Stückchen auch ein ein ein massives
Alarmzeichen weil wir ja sehen dass die
islamistische Szene gerade nicht wieder
zum Leben und zum Z sagen nicht noch mal
erwacht weil geschlafen haben sie nie
aber die werden wieder stärker und das
ist
brandgefährlich wie viele von denen sind
festgenommen worden gegen wie viele das
weiß ich nicht was ich aber weiß ist
dass W das auf jeder demonstra
die sich massiv darum bemüht dass sie
alle Straftaten auch tatsächlich
identifizieren und dass sie dagegen
ermitteln aber wir haben
Umsetzungsproblem wir haben
Umsetzungsproblem weil wir nicht genug
Personal haben bei der bei der Polizei
weil wir nicht genug Leute haben die
auch tatsächlich die slogens alle
erkennen weil die Symboliken nicht alle
eindeutig sind tatsächlich für
diejenigen die sich darum kümmern müssen
und das ist dring notwendig dass wir da
deutlich und zwar sehr schnell deutlich
besser
W gleich wir reden gleich darüber was
das heißt aber würde erst noch die
Landrätin in der Runde fragen wenn Sie
das sehen als als Frau von der Basis was
denken Sie dannr npur wie es gerade
darauf hin na ja wir haben da ein
Umsetzungsproblem und die Polizei ich
wenn man mit Polizisten spricht mit
Polizeibeamten spricht die auch an
ähnlichen Demonstrationen in Hamburg
z.B Dienst hatten die sagen die weißt es
ist unfassbar hart du stehst dann da
wenn ich nur eine Spur zu hart bin ist
der nächste Vorwurf
Rassist das sind Vorwurfe die wir wir
egal in welcher Dimension wir ich sag
mal nicht Mehrheitsbevölkerung
ansprechen erleben an an ganz vielen
Stellen ja die Ohnmacht ist da denn zum
einen haben wir niemals genug Polizisten
es sind unsere Ordnungsbehörden auch der
Landkreise die darüber entscheiden ob
eine solche Demonstration stattfinden
kann oder nicht und es ist ganz
schwierig etwas abzulehnen wenn im
Vorfeld z.B für Palästina für die
Gesundheit von Menschen für Frieden
demonstriert werden soll und man nicht
genau nachvollziehen kann was wirklich
gemacht wird und dann können sie ja gar
nicht eingreifen wenn sie Hunderte von
aggressiven Menschen vor sich haben ist
auch Leib und Leben nicht mehr sicher
der Polizisten wenn die eingreifen
würden wir leben auf dem Land bei mir im
Landkreis das heißt eine solche Demo
würden wir nicht erleben aber sie ist
glaube ich ein Spiegelbild dessen was
wir auch in den kleinen Zellen in den
kleineren Gemeinden dieses der Republik
auch an gedankenut erleben auch wenn es
nicht auf der Straße in dieser Form
sichtbar ist aber die Frage ist doch
inwieweit die ganze Politik ob im
kleinen oder im großen eigentlich diese
Toleranz gegenüber den intoleranten
sozusagen gewährt oder wie man wie man
als Staat damit umgeht und wenn man dann
von vorne rein sagt es gibt eigentlich
nicht genug Personal um sowas zu
verhindern dann ist das äh armutszeugn
sagt man so schnell aber dann ist das
etwas was das Sicherheitsgefühl in
diesem Land
nicht stärkt und die Idee dass man ein
Kalifat fordert Männer und Frauen
getrennt auf deutsche Straßen gehen ich
frag mich dann immer was wollen die
eigentlich hier also dann ist es wo
anders schöner zu leben als ausgerechnet
in diesem freiheitlichen Land wenn man
diese Werte gar nicht mehr teilt ich ich
schau g zu Herrn güin da begin schon das
Problem weil woanders gibt's in dem Fall
nicht wir werden gleich ein Ausschnitt
sehen einer der radikalsten Sprecher der
spricht deutsch und ich nehme an der
Mann ist auch hier im Land geboren ich
weiß es nicht genau es können Sie uns
vielleicht erklären aber vielleicht
können wir erst einmal über diese über
diese Flaggen reden über diese Symbolik
sprechen was steht da drauf das ist ist
ist das in irgendeiner Form justiziabel
oder ist das harmlos nein das ist ja das
traurige also als ich die Bilder in
Essen gesehen habe war ich gar nicht
überrascht weil diese Bewegung die
dahinter steckt die barier wie sie ja
schon gesagt haben seit 2003 eigentlich
mit einem Betätigungsverbot belegt seit
2003 seit 2003 Otto Schile lang ist es
her und 20 Jahre und das sagt uns ja
auch also letzte Woche wo dir auch Hamas
mit deem
Betätigungsverbot belegt und auchun das
sind wichtige Schritte um juristische
Handhabe zu haben aber dadurch
verschwinden diese Leute nicht Dieb
Bewegung ist heute aktiver als sie je
war vor 2003 und also aktiver als zu
Chilis Zeiten
alsverb wir sind jetzt natürlich
aufgewacht weil wir zum ersten Mal mit
diesen Bildern in Essen konfrontiert
wurden aber das ist auch nichts Neues
sondern die die Plattformen die die
Leute hier in Deutschland haben das ist
Generation Islam Islam Muslim interaktiv
das sind sozusagen Organisationen die
daraus her vorgegangen sind das sind
Social Media Plattform mit enormer
Reichweite und sie haben vor allem junge
Muslime im Visier und die agieren schon
seit Jahren also es gab 2020 ein sehr
gut sehr gute inszenierte Aufmarsch am
brendenburger Tor da gab's kein
Aufschrei großartigen von der Politik
erst vor wenigen Monaten in Hamburg
gab's anlässlich der Koranverbrennungen
in Schweden sie auch 3 4000 Menschen
mobilisiert auch Männer und Frauen
getrennt also das ist kein neues
Phänomen jetzt aber her noripo sagt
jetzt gibt's natürlich eine gewisse
Aufmerksamkeit bei der Politik weil
diese Bilder noch mal eine neue
Intensität ist und das war das was in
Essen stad gefunden hat war eine
Machtdemonstration sie haben bisher
eigentlich immer diese Flaggen nie so
wirklich offen gezeigt wie jetzt in
Essen sie haben immer versucht die
Symbole zu verwischen damit es keinen
klaren Bezug zu his
gibt aber diesmal haben sie es
offensiv bewusst gemacht also es ist
wirklich eine Machtdemonstration aber um
jetzt auch mal als gläubiger Muslim zu
sprechen sie haben ja gefragt was was
steht da ist das justitiabel das ist ja
das traurige das ist unser
Glaubensbekenntnis oder was das was auf
diesem Fahne steht ist das
Glaubensbekenntnis der Muslime und das
tut natürlich mir als als gläubigen
Muslim weh wenn ich sehe dass mein
Glauben Bekenntnis was für mich von
hoher Bedeutung hat von solchen
extremistischen
ähm ja Leuten äh pervertiert wird und
das das ist auch ein Punkt um vielleicht
noch einen Punkt zu
nennen es gibt ein Aufschrei in der
Öffentlichkeit in den Medien in der
Politik was mir aber weh tut ist dass es
kein Aufschrei von uns Muslimen gibt
weil da da mit diesen Bildern das was
dort bei
den Zuschauern der deutschen
Öffentlichkeit ausgelöst wird ist ja nur
Negativität gegenüber meinen Glauben und
eigentlich bevor überhaupt die Politik
oder die deutschen Medien aufschreien
müssten eigentlich wir als deutsche
Muslime sagen ich überlasse die
Definition zit über meinen Glauben nicht
solchen Extremisten wir haben gerade das
vielleicht können wir das noch einmal
zeigen das das Foto gesehen ne ich meine
ja die Analogie ist klar also Taliban
steht ähnliches drauf also is z.B was
steht da drauf das das ist dasselbe nur
in anderem Design andere Schriftart aber
viele extremistische Organisation sei
der Hamas sei der is sei die Taliban sei
das iranische Regime sei die
Staatsflagge von
Saudi-Arabien also die diese Symbolik
diese Schriftzüge kommen überall vor sei
es
Muslime die sufist sind die spirituell
sind und eigentlich überhaupt nicht mit
extremistischen Gedanken haben auch bei
ih spielt dieses Schriftzug natürlich
eine große Rolle und das ist glaube ich
ein ein ein zentraler Punkt wo wir
Muslime hier in Deutschland aber auch in
der islamischen Welt eigentlich
insgesamt eigentlich auf die Straßen
gehen sollten und diese Definitionsmacht
der definitionshoheit über unsere
Religion und über die religiösen Symbole
zurückerobern müssen ich ich ich habe
jetzt mehrere Fragen an sie ich muss
einmal kurz weil weil sie da sehr
kompeten sindüber wir haben immer ein B
gesehen vielleicht können wir das auch
noch mal zeigen das Kalifat ist die
Lösung was heißt das was ist die Idee
dahinter das ist eine zentrale Säule der
Ideologie der hisbutarir die hisbutarir
ist eine
islamistische
kalifatsbewegung und sie lehnen jede
Form von Demokratie ab sie lehnen auch
z.B
Erdogan oder oder andere Regime die
eigentlich nicht demokratisch sind aber
aber Demokrat
demoktische sulierenar das lehnen sie ab
und das Interessante ist auch essen dass
dort keine palästinensische Fahne auch
zugelassen war weil jede Fahne sei
Palästina Türkei egal was Nationalstaat
lehnen sie ab Demokratie lehnen sie ab
Rechtsstaat nehmen lehnen sie ab sondern
die Lösung für Palästina Konflikt
überhaupt für die Unterdrückung der
Muslime durch den Westen durch die USA
durch die Zionisten durch die jüdische
Weltverschwörung wenn man das bekämpfen
will geht nur über einen Weg und das ist
die Umma die weltweite
Glaubensgemeinschaft der Muslime indem
sie das Kalifat etabliert klare Führung
und Kare Führung konkret wie würde das
aussehen also was ist das Zentrum dieses
weltweiten Kalifats Barbarei das ist
also Taliban versied
ma würden das ja nicht zulassen kann war
sehr interessant vor ein paar Jahren in
in luten Kleinstadt in der Nähe von
London die berüchtigt dafür ist dass es
dort sehr sehr viele Islamisten gibt und
ich hatte die die Gelegenheit zwei von
denen zu sprechen kam gerade aus der
Koranschule und einer davon ein ein
russischer Konvertit und sein sein
bester Freund ein Somali erst sagten wir
sind Muslime wir sind freundliche
Menschen und so weiter und haben großen
Respekt vor dem Gesetz und vor Frauen
sowieso und als man dann anfing
nachzufragen und so weiter stellte sich
raus sie haben ganz andere Dinge im Kopf
und fingen an über den Westen
herzuziehen und zu schimpfen und dann
sagte ich irgendwann an einem Punkt gäbe
es für euch beide nicht viel schönere
Orte z.B Riad oder den Sinai oder sowas
Antwort da waren wir schon wir sind dort
raus geflogen die wollen diese Leute
nicht haben weil sie ihnen zu gefährlich
erscheinen ist das für sie plausibel
ich meine das saudische Königshaus hat
ja eine gewisse Zeit lang den Wahabismus
den salfismus gepredigt und auch
versucht weltweit über ihre Petrodollars
zu zu exportieren aber sie haben
natürlich gerade als al-Qaida
hervorgekommen ist und und sehr schnell
halt auch gemerkt dass sie eigentlich
dort ein Monster gezüchtet haben der
außer Kontrolle geht redt und der sich
auch gegen das
Königshaus richtet Saudi-Arabien ist
alles andere als demokratisch wir kennen
die Situation auch die
Menschenrechtslage aber
islamistische Bewegungen und
kalifatsbewegungen würden dort keinerlei
Raum bekommen ne und und gerade
der der der Kronprinz jetzt der ist ja
besonders der ist ja besonders rigide
gegen solche Leute sie wissen ganz genau
wie gefährlich solche Leute sind weil
sie eine Zeit lang natürlich natürlich
auch ähnliche islamistische
Gruppierungen weltweit
gefördert haben es die
islamische Universität in Medina
das ist die zweite heilige Stadt nach
meckka die dritte ist Jerusalem
interessanterweise das war sozusagen
diese Universität war sozusagen
hauptausbildungsort für radikale
Prediger wie kennen ja noch Pier Vogel
der war ja vor einigen Jahren noch gern
gesehener Gast bei deutschen Talkshows
weil er natürlich
ne bei ih nicht aber bei anderen und ist
natürlich exotische Figur reinländische
Akzent Konvertit und so er z.B hat an
dieser Medina Universität studiert und
dort diesen ideologischen Unterbau
bekommen aber man sieht halt auch sogar
in Saudi-Arabien so eine interessante
Entwicklung dass sie sehen dass sie im
eigenen Land solche Leute die finden da
gar keinen freien Raum und sie gehen da
natürlich rabiat gegen die vor gen vor
und die die beiden Herren die ich da
getroffen hab waren genau solche
Menschen die die dort nicht mehr haben
wollten und Ägypten genauso ist auch
einer der Gründe warum die Ägypter sagen
Gaza wir machen da nicht auf weil dann
laufen wir Gefahr uns genau diese Leute
wieder ins Land zu holen was sehr
tragisch
ist Herr gyvin sagt gerade Herr nuripur
diese Leute würden in
Saudi-Arabien nie ein Raum kriegen warum
dann in Essen einmal wenn wir jetzt
beispielwe Pier Vogel nehmen das sind
also Leute die hier geboren sind die
deutsche Staatsbürger sind Konvertiten
das ist unsere Verantwortung sich dem zu
stellen aber wie stellen wir wie stellen
wir uns dem ein Satz noch und dann dann
sofort die gerne versuche ich eine
Antwort es ist komplett wirklich
komplexe Situation und schwieriges
Problem aber wir müssen das ganz
dringend und schnell angehen und wir
haben sehr viel Zeit tatsächlich auch
vergehen lassen Saudi-Arabien ist kein
rchtsstaat die die stecken die Leute vor
in Folter KK wenn es wenn es gebraucht
wird das ist für uns Gott sei dan keine
Option wir müssen uns andere Wege
überlegen Härte des des Rechtsstaates
Strafgesetzbuch umsetzen konsequent ähm
und und vieles andere mehr aber ich will
auf noch etwas Hinweisen es ist ja
gerade völlig zurecht drauf hingewiesen
worden äh dass äh jetzt nicht besonders
laut und und veherent jetzt von
muslimischer Seite die letzten Tage
parteier ergriffen oder die letzten
Wochen parteier ergriffen worden ist für
das Land was angegriffen wird von Terror
und das ist Israel wir beide haben vom
Brandenburger Tor gesprochen so viel
mehr fällt mir jetzt gerade auch nicht
ein ähm gleichzeitig aber muss man aber
auch sehen wir haben nicht geschafft die
letzten Jahre ausreichend alles dafür zu
tun um einen deutschen Islam zu
etablieren es gibt beispielsweise eine
Islamkonferenz die Tag seit 2006 die
haben bestimmt ganz viel großartiges
hinbekommen aber die zentralen Fragen
nicht gelöst drei zentralen Fragen sind
wir brauchen Verbände Vereine Moscheen
die Deutsch sind deutsche Strukturen
haben deutsches Personal haben und
Deutsch finanziert werden wo das Geld
herkommt kommt Einfluss mit und
dementsprechend ist ja eingangs gesagt
worden wenn wenn die Türkei die die
Moscheen finanziert und dann auch noch
einmal die Woche quasi eine leidpredigt
kommt aus Ankara was erzählt werden soll
und dieser leidpredigt steht
dementsprechend dass Israel jetzt
schrecklich wä und und die Israel ist
schuld sein an dem was da passiert und
das haben wir gesehen die letzten Wochen
mehrfach ist ist passiert ne jetzt
genauso ist es passiert sie können sich
a zu zitieren dann dann dann haben wir
ein mächtig großes Problem dass wir
beenden müssen und deshalb ist diese
Finanzierungsfrage die Personalfrage
dass die jenigen die predigen auch nicht
in Ankara oder woanders ausgebildet
worden sind sondern bei uns wir haben
Pilotprojekte ganz viele und die sind
auch echt toll aber wir müssen eendlich
mal in die Fläche kommen damit und das
haben wir die letzten Jahre nicht
geschafft das ist riesen
verersagen noch mal sie sagen wir haben
da ein echtes Problem und sie sie
beklagen das jetzt jar glaubwürdig das
nehme ich ihn auch ab aber sie sind
quasi Teil der Regierung also Sie haben
es doch in der Hand das zu ändern ja das
müssen wir auch ändern es
wir haben halt di die üblichen Geflechte
von von von Bund und und und Ländern und
vieles andere mehr und ehrlich gesag
üblichen Geflechte von Ländern
Bildungsfragen wenn wir jetzt davon
sprechen dass Religionsunterricht an
deutschen Schulen z.B stattfinden soll
von Lehren Lehrern die an deutschen
Universitäten ausgebildet worden sind
dann dann ist es keine Angelegenheit die
jetzt eine Bundesregierung sie doch
nicht mit mit ein bisschen Bildung hier
nein das kriege ich nicht mit Bildung
gelöst das kriege ich nur mittim
Strafgesetzbuch und nur mit der mit
einer funktionierenden Guten
sicherheitsapparatur hin aber noch
le Kön no nicht mal sagen klar ich we
ich weiß von dieser ein Demo nicht ich
weiß dass die Zahl der der
antisemitischen Vorfälle die letzten
vier Wochen um 2600 gestiegen ist aber
wie viele von diesen Leuten sitzen im
Gefängnis ich weiß es nicht aber in dem
rechtstad sitzt nach vier Wochen
normalerweise niemand ausgerüt hat im
Gefängnis ich frag nur deswegen was gab
in Frankreich GZ kurz einzigen Satz noch
sagen ich wird ich wir es geht nicht
darum dass wir mit mit Bildungsarbeit
jetzt diesen Leuten jetzt das Handwerk
legen können es geht nur nur mit herte
aber mit Bildungsarbeit kann man
schaffen dass die nicht Leute mitziehen
die die die die nicht ausreichend
gebildet sind z.B über ihre eigene
Religion und sich am Ende bei bei
falschen Videos auf Youtube informieren
oder eben salafistische Hassreden
anhören und sagen das soll man glaube
sein dann gehe ich auf diese Demo her
güin sie wollten gerade ich wollte
nuralber etwas kurz korrigieren also es
gab Predigten der türkischen
Religionsbehörde dianet in der Türkei
die
extrem antisemitisch waren und Israel
Hetze beinhaltet haben
und diese Predigten werden aber nicht in
den Diti Moscheen gehalten die haben
ihre eigene Predigt aber
das ist gar nicht auch entscheidend
sondern der wichtige Punkt ist
die Imame der ditip die verlesen hier
zwar eine andere Predigt eine softe
Predigt eine im deutschen Kontext nicht
äh eine eine Wellness Predigt genau aber
die die Rolle der türkischen
Religionsbehörde diet und das erlebe ich
immer wieder in Gespräch mit
Politikern jeglicher colur also
parteiübergreifend dietip gibt es seit
1984 seit nächstes Jahr 40 Jahr und
sogar Politiker die sich mit
religionspolitischen Fragen beschäftigen
verstehen immer noch nicht wie die
Struktur ditip funktioniert ihr Wissen
über die ditip Struktur basiert im
Grunde genommen auf Wikipedia und das
ist wirklich erschreckend zu sehen weil
man muss verstehen wie diese Struktur
funktioniert diese alle erbasch der seit
dem 7 sich täglich in seiner
antisemitischen Hetze übertrifft das ist
der leit Chef der türkischen
Religionsbehörde und er ist der sitzt in
Ankara der sitzt in Ankara genau und
dieser al Erbas ist aber das religiöse
Oberhaupt der ditip in Deutschland und
er ist der diensthererr der über 900
ditip Imame weil die Imame der ditip
hier in Deutschland sind Beamte des
türkischen Staates er ist der
dienstherer und das steht alles in der
ditipsatzung schwarz auf weiß er ist
auch der
Beiratsvorsitzender das ist jetzt nicht
irgendwie ein Beirat der keine große
Funktion hat sondern dieser Beirat hat
mehr Macht als alle ditip Landesverbände
in den einzelnen bundesländernern er
bestimmt wer der dittipchef hier in
Deutschland ist er bestimmt die
Leitlinie wir haben seit 2006 die
Deutsche Islamkonferenz aber die
bisherige Strategie aller
Bundesregierungen und da sind alle
Parteien Schuld daran oder oder sind
verantwortlich dafür ja wir wollen jetzt
auch niemanden speziell Anlagen generell
verstehen was das Thema ist das Problem
ist man hat jahrelang daran festgehalten
Wandel durch Nähe man erzeugt
Näheverhältnis zu solchen Strukturen und
man erhofft sich dass sie sich
reformieren dass sie sich wandeln und
wirklich zu deutschen religions
Gemeinschaften werden aber ist ja auch
ein freundlicher Ansatz ist ja per sehr
nett aber wir einigen Jahren ein
spionageskandal wir hatten etliche
antisemitische Vorfälle und jetzt ist
die Tip nicht in der Lage sich zu Hamas
zu positionieren und vor allem die
entscheidende Frage ist das religiöse
Oberhaupt ist der größte antisemitische
Hetzer der letzten vier Wochen gewesen
erdan spricht von Freiheitskämpfern und
Sie können sich dazu nicht Verhalten man
man es gibt Presseanfragen in der
ditipzentrale sie Antworten nicht darauf
und das muss politische
konquenen Land also weil über diese
Struktur die ist die Türkei und damit
halt auch Erdogan er gestaltet das
muslimische Leben in Deutschland mehr
als ich Deutscher Muslim oder Herr
nuripur oder die Bundesregierung und das
kann es halt nicht sein und wenn es an
nach dem siebten Zeitenwende ist ja so
ein Modebegriff geworden ich hoffe dass
ist nicht nur ein Lippenbekenntnis oder
einfach nur Rhetorik PR Rhetorik wir
brauchen auch eine religionspolitische
Zeitenwende das fordere ich von meiner
Bundesregierung als muslimischer
Staatsbürger dieses Landes das ist meine
Forderung darf ich für das ganze Bild
noch eine Nachfrage stellen ist das der
Mann der sich kürzlich auch mit Taliban
getroffen hat genau er hatte zu einer
dringlichkeitskonferenz
Online genau das ist er und da waren
auch äh von dem islamischen Emirat äh
Afghanistan also die Taliban auch
zugeschaltet absolut klar weil wenn es
um Israel geht sind alle auf derselben
Linie Kollegen aus der Regie sind sehr
schnell glaube wir haben das sogar
vorlegen können wir das einmal kurz
zuspielen interessant das mal zu
zeigen Jerusalem gehört den
Muslimen Palästina und Gaza sind
Heimatländer der Muslime und werden es
bis ans Ende der Zeit
bleiben das zionistische Israel begeht
in Gaza ein Völkermord mit seinen
Angriffen die auf sch undven
glaubenen
g wow da ist genau dieses wording ne der
Völkermord in Gaza von Israel kein Wort
von Hamas kein Wort von perverser glaube
so unglaublich das ist der Mann noch mal
über 900 Imame in den in Deutschland
nicht nur ditip Moscheen sondern auch in
den attip Moscheen ATIP ist ein
türkischer Verband im sogenannten
Zentralrat der Muslime diese Feinheiten
wissen viele nicht
also nicht nur dietip also über 900
ditip Gemeinden aber auch bei ATIP
Gemeinden und
der sogenannte Zentralrat der Muslim ist
ja auch gern gesehen der Gast
bei der Politik ger ein bisschen
sprachlos Frau Frau Münstermann wollte
und dann dürfen sie sofort dann nur ja
ich glaube dass das Bild wird dann
größer also das weiß man ja schon sie
auch in der Politik in den letzten
Jahren der merkelreierung hat man eine
Flüchtlingspolitik in in Deutschland
darauf gegründet dass es ein Abkommen
mit Erdogan gab das Türkei eutürkei
Abkommen das ja jetzt auch immer wieder
so dieung flüchtlingsdiel genau also
Geld und dafür werden Flüchtlinge nicht
aus der Türkei nach Europa geschickt
jetzt gibt ja immer wieder Forderung
auch angesichts der aktuellen Zahlen
sowas reloadet sozusagen also erneut
Geld und aber das glaube ich begründet
den Umgang mit Erdogan dem Erdogan
Regime denn diese titp also man überlegt
sich das gürteintitut würde in
islamischen Ländern christliche äh äh
wahnsinnige an die Spitze stellen und
würde rausgehen und und den Kindern in
den Schulen Dinge predigen die gegen das
eigene Land gerichtet sind also man muss
ja immer mal diese andere Perspektive
einnehmen will trotem für das Protokoll
sagen also V meinem christlichen
Hintergrund wir haben sehr lange
Missionare und tun wir immer noch in
aller her Länder geschickt zu Menschen
die niederach gefragt hatten willst nur
fürs Protokoll sagen stimmt aber aber
dazu gehört do wir sind ja jetzt 20 23
sie haben völlig recht wir habenus was g
aus den Fehlern haben wir ja gelernt
hoffe ich aber dann muss man ja sagen
warum lassen wir uns das denn also was
soll das aber ich glaube die
Verständigung gerade weil hier so viele
Türken wunderbar leben und zwar seit X
Generationen in Deutschland sucht man
die Nähe zum türkischen Staat halte ich
auch für richtig halte das auch für
falsch wenn man sagt wir reden nicht
mehr also gerade angesichts der Lage
jetzt ist es wichtig mit Erdogan zu
reden nur diese Toleranz noch mal also
eine eine Toleranz gegenüber Leuten die
die selbst nicht üben ist fatal gerade
erdan sagen und damit wir alle sozusagen
das das gleiche Bild haben Erdogan Hetze
gegen Israel haben wir auch noch im
Angebot
bitte die Hamas ist keine terroristische
Organisation sondern eine befreiungs und
mutchahadingruppe die einen Kampf zum
Schutz ihres Landes und ihrer Bürger
führt haben kein Problem mit dem Staat
Israel aber wir haben Israels Greultaten
und die Tatsache dass es als
Organisation und nicht als Staat agiert
nie
akzeptiert und werden dies auch nicht
tun seit dem 7 Oktober führt Israel
einen der blutigsten abscheulichsten und
brutalsten Angriffe der Geschichte gegen
unschuldige Menschen im Gazastreifen
durch so ein Teil der der üblichen
retorik auch üblichen Floskeln ne
unschuldige Zivilisten als ob es
Schuldige Zivilisten gäbe nie verstanden
aber ganz abgesehen davon also der der
Völkermord kein Wort von man kann ja
israelische Politik kritisieren das kann
man ja machen das darf er auch aber das
ist ja nicht Kritik an israelische
Politik Kritik das ist einfach eindeutig
eine Verdrehung der Tatsachen ähm dass
dass die Hamas keine Terrororganisation
wäre wenn die Hamas keine ist gibt's
keine Terrororganisation tut mir einfach
leid ich meine die gehen auf auf
Festivals und Schlachten Leute ab und
das ist jetzt ehrlich gesagt der der der
absolute Tiefpunkt von von von mehreren
Jahrzehnten Terror äh die haben die
haben als sie in in Gaza sich an die
Macht geputscht haben als erstes die
ganzen offiziellen der Autorität der
palästinensischen Autorität an die Wand
gestellt und umgebracht das ist einfach
alles grotesk äh und
ist jenseits von vom akzeptierbaren und
akzeptablen und deshalb hat hat Frau
münstelmanann völlig recht es ist
richtig dass wir erwarten und ich gehe
auch davon aus dass es passiert dass
wenn Erdogan in zwei Wochen nach
Deutschland kommt dass dieses diese e
auch alle sehr deutlich angesprochen
werden das müssen wir tun stimmt
gleichzeitig möchte ich aber davor
warnen das jetzt komplett auf auf die
türkeigeschichten zu zu schieben wir
sitzen jetzt in Hamburg hier um die Ecke
ist das islamische Zentrum
Hamburg die werden weitgehen aus dem
Iran finanziert ich bleibe bei meiner
Einschätzung die Blaue Moschee genau und
und was sie mit dem Geld machen ist
offensichtlich die die spionieren und
die die Exiliraner aus und und Spellen
sie aus und und Schü sie wei man alles
das ist alles aktenkundig und seit wie
vielen Jahren weiß man das äh ich weiß
dass wir seit zwei
Jahren oder spätestens seit der
Revolution im Iran letztes Jahr jetzt
täglich daruf warten dass diese Mosche
geschlossen wird und es ist auch in
Hamburg Gott sei dan was passiert dass
sie nämlich aus dem staatsvertrage
geflogen sind es war überfällig Moral
der Geschichte ist wir brauchen einfach
ein Stopp dieser ausländischen Gelder
die hier Unruhe stiften Unfriedens
stiften und unsägliches bewerkstelligen
und die Leute in dahin führen dass diese
nicht nur diese Bilder haben sondern
diese Taten haben die wir hier nicht
akzeptieren können und deshalb ist
dieser dieser inner deutsche Islam der
nicht drauf angewiesen ist dass aus
Ankara predigigen und Geld kommt und aus
Teran und aus Riad oder wo auch immer
das ist das was es dringen brauchen und
das diskutieren wir seit 30 Jahren in
der Politik und seit 40 oder oder es ist
ermütend dass wir da nicht hinkommen und
das muss jetzt passieren ich habe da so
eine Lehrstelle in meinem Kopf und würde
die gerne füllen mit einer Antwort von
Herrn güin würde gerne einmal wissen von
ihnen ich meine das was da passiert äh
auch diese offenkundige Verbindung zum
Islam ich meine es waren ja keine
katholischen Pfadfinder die dadurch
Essen marschiert sind sondern es waren
Muslime
äh aber in ihrer radikalsten Ausprägung
was ist denn abschließend um den Themen
Komplex einmal rundzumachen aus ihrer
Sicht notwendig um das einmal zu
verändern weil das ist natürlich auch
ein Schlag ins Gesicht von so vielen
gemäßigten Muslimen die auch in diesem
Land leben und die das genauso furchtbar
finden wie alle anderen auch aber Sie
müssen aufschreien also wenn wenn wenn
nach dem 7 Oktober und ich habe viele
jüdische freundinnne Freunde die mir das
auch wirklich geschildert haben im was
für ein Ausnahmezustand Jüdin und Juden
in Deutschland leben Muslime die in
Deutschland leben die immer glücklich
darüber waren als damals der ehemalige
Bundespräsident Wolf gesagt hat Islam
ist ein Teil Deutschland ist wenn wenn
man das so toll findet dass Islam ein
Teil Deutschland ist
ich mE ich brauche jetzt kein
Bundespräsidenten der mir bescheinigen
muss dass ich jetzt Teil Deutschlands
bis aber es ist ja ein Symbol und das
ist bei vielen Muslimen sehr gut
angekommen aber das das gut zu finden
aber auf der anderen Seite die deutsche
Geschichte und die Verantwortung nicht
zu verinnerlichen und auch zu eigener
Verantwortung zu machen dass ich auch
als Deutscher Muslim einen Beitrag zu
leisten habe für die Sicherheit von
Jüdin Juden in Deutschland dieses
Bewusstsein fehlt und dann hat man
muslimische Vertreter die ja von sich
sagen sie sein Religionsgemeinschaften
meiner Meinung nach sind keine
Religionsgemeinschaften aber sie
vertreten diesen Anspruch dann hat man
gesellschaftliche Verantwortung wie man
das auch von christlichen Kirchen
Funktionären erwarten würde müssen auch
muslimische Verbandsfunktionäre beim
Thema muslimischen
Antisemitismus das in ihren Gemeinden
thematisieren nicht für praktionen in in
bei der Politik ähm etwas Versprechungen
geben die man aber nicht in die
Gemeinden kommuniziert Synagogen
besuchen aber Bilder von den Synagogen
besuchen nirgendswo in in ihren sozialen
Netzwerken oder auf ihren Webseiten
posten weil sie ganz genau wissen was
von ein antisemitischen schitztorm sie
begegnen wird und das ist im Grunde
genommen das ist geschehen letzte Woche
ein dpfunktionär hat die Synagoge in
Köln besucht so nach dem Motto ist es
eine
rehabilitierungseinrichtung für mich als
gescheiterten Verbandsfunktionär damit
ich mich nach diesen öffentlichen
politischen Druck wieder für die
deutsche Öffentlichkeit für die deutsche
Politik als
ert präsentieren kann aber keins von
diesen Fotos das wä ein schönes Signal
gewesen nicht auf der ditip Webseite
nicht auf den Social Media Accounts
nirgendswo weil sie ganz genau wissen
dann wäre der Antisemitismus in den
eigenen Strukturen wä für uns alle die
jetzt ich habe vielleicht ein Einblick
in die muslimische Community aber viele
haben ja keinen Einblick dann würde man
das ja auch mitbekommen und dann hilft
es auch nicht
wennan mas vom sogenannten Zentralrat
der Muslime dann in Interviews sagt ja
Antisemitismus ist eine Sünde im Islam
ja drogenverkaufen ist auch eine Sünde
im Islam Bankraub ist auch Sünde ist
Islam aber es gibt muslimische
Drogendealer muslimische Antisemiten und
es gibt muslimische Antisemiten die
ihren Antisemitismus Israel Hass auch
religiös argumentieren der Koran ist ein
Werkzeugkasten für jeden jeder kann sich
da etwas zusammenbasteln wer was er will
aber deswegen gibt's ja
Religionsgemeinschaften religiöse
Autoritäten und diese religiösen
Autoritäten müssen sich positionieren
und wenn diese muslimischen
Religionsgemeinschaften sogenannten in
Deutschland das nicht machen dann müssen
alle anderen Muslime die Stimme erheben
und sich klar positionieren okay